This is gold, look at that, Andre, the man, the myth, the legend, taking a stroll through the catalog of ADSP. And that's why I joined NVIDIA, and I'll tell you exactly why. I want to mooch. And I'll explain exactly what I mean by mooching. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 68, recorded on February 15th, 2022. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we interview Andre Alexandrescu. This is part one of a two-part interview. Perfect, perfect. two-part interview perfect perfect all right so you were saying that uh you went back and listened to a bunch of the episodes we'll cut this up so just so you know i i put some polish we cut things in and out but um what were you gonna say first of all i should let you know that uh according
这话太绝了，看呐，安德烈，这位传奇人物，正在浏览ADSP的目录。这就是我加入NVIDIA的原因，我来具体讲讲为什么。我想去“蹭”。我会具体解释我说的“蹭”是什么意思。欢迎来到ADSP播客，第68期，录制于2022年2月15日。我是康纳，今天我和我的联合主持人布莱斯一起采访安德烈·亚历山德雷斯库。这是两部分采访的第一部分。完美，完美，两部分采访，完美，完美，好的，刚才你说你回去听了一大堆往期节目，我们会把这段剪掉，所以提前跟你说一声，我做了一些润色，我们会剪辑进出一些内容，但是，你刚才想说什么来着？首先，我应该让你知道，根据
to audacity i'm getting into like a high green zone and sometimes if i get too excited i'm getting into like a high green zone. And sometimes if I get too excited, I'm getting into the red zone. So maybe it's a bit loud. So I turn it just a bit quieter, if that's okay with you. Yeah, I think that's fine. I mean, I think I get into the red zone quite frequently. Ah, okay. Good, good, good. Yeah.
Audacity显示，我的声音已经进入了较高的绿色区域，有时候如果我太兴奋的话，声音就会进入较高的绿色区域。有时候如果我太兴奋，它甚至会进入红色区域。所以声音可能有点大。如果可以的话，我把它调小一点。行，我觉得没问题。我是说，我觉得我自己经常进入红色区域。啊，好吧，很好，很好。
The odds that you're louder than Bryce are 0%. So fun story back when the C++ committee would have, um, face-to-face meetings, I became infamous for, uh, my infamous, even though I know that's got to work on your infamous, this is going great. I became infamous for, uh, how I would use my voice at the breaks to announce that it was the end of break. I would just go out and I would shout in my loudest voice, like, breaks over, get back to work. And I have been told by some people that towards the end of break, they move to the opposite side of the room. They wouldn't want to be there, yeah.
你声音比布莱斯更大的概率是0%。有一个有趣的往事，以前C++委员会开面对面会议的时候，我因为我那“臭名昭著”的——虽然我知道我得改改这个词，这次采访进展得太顺利了——我因为在茶歇时用我的大嗓门宣布茶歇结束而“名声大噪”。我就会直接走到外面，用我最大的声音喊，比如“茶歇结束，回去工作”。有人跟我说，快到茶歇结束的时候，他们都会搬到房间的另一头去。他们可不想待在那儿，对吧。
They don't want to have any damage to their eardrums. Bryce's siren song, you know? Yeah. Yeah, my voice goes pretty loud. I can tell this is going to be great. This is going to be up there and in contention with our Sean Parent episode. Hang on. Before we go any further, I got wrecked by Wordle today because, Connor, as I'm sure you know, we had the first three letters of our word arose.
他们可不想耳膜受损。布莱斯的“海妖之歌”，你知道的？对，对。我的嗓门确实挺大的。我看得出来这次访谈会非常棒。这期节目绝对能跟我们采访肖恩·帕特的那一期一较高下。等等。在我们继续之前，我今天在玩Wordle时被虐惨了，因为康纳，如你所知，我们这个词的前三个字母是arose。
We had all of them match and all of them in position. And I did not get it in two. I got it in three. Wow. Is there even another word? What did you guess? It's A-R-O-I-D or I-T, which was not a word that I knew. I was just trying things and I didn't expect it to go through.
我们所有的字母都匹配了，而且位置也完全正确。但我没能在两步内猜出来。我用了三步。哇。难道还有别的词吗？你猜的是什么？是A-R-O-I-D或者A-R-O-I-T，这不是我认识的词。我当时只是在瞎蒙，根本没指望能对。
All right. Well, everyone, the listener, you can feel bad for Bryce. Back to Andre, though, because now Bryce has interrupted our esteemed guest twice. He was telling us about his – I actually don't know where you were going to go. You were just telling us that you were listening to the past episodes. I was just saying that I was watching your past episodes with Eric Niebler, with Sean Parent. Eric Niebler and his dad, it turns out. Yep, Otto Niebler.
好吧，各位听众，你们可以为布莱斯感到难过。不过我们还是回到安德烈这里吧，因为布莱斯现在已经打断了我们的尊贵嘉宾两次了。他刚才正要讲他的——其实我不知道你刚才想往哪儿扯。你刚才只是在说你在听过去的节目。我本来只是想说我在看你们和埃里克·尼布勒、肖恩·帕特的往期节目。结果发现还有埃里克·尼布勒和他的父亲。没错，奥托·尼布勒。
That was pretty awesome. And with Sean and with Patricia and Chandler and all these fine folks. And they had all these awesome, interesting stories. And I was thinking, oh, my goodness, what am I going to produce here? What possible thing of interest could I ever see on this podcast? Are you kidding? All right. Well, let's go from there.
那真的太棒了。还有肖恩、帕特里夏、钱德勒以及所有这些优秀的伙伴们。他们有那么多精彩、有趣的故事。当时我在想，哦天哪，我在这里会产出什么呢？在这个播客里，我究竟能讲出什么哪怕有一点吸引力的东西？你在开玩笑道吧？好吧，那我们就从这里开始吧。
Or have you thought, wait, am I interrupting you now? Because I'm about to intercept and be like, are you kidding? But go ahead. Say what you're going to say. You know, here's the thing um i think that the world has gotten a bit uh polarized in the sense that you either want to hear a story where you kind of like died then came back alive or there's no interest right so there's this extreme you know i don't want a story of like some sub story from a kid who grew up in communist Romania.
或者你觉得——等等，我现在是不是又在打断你？因为我正准备插话来一句“你在开玩笑道吧”。不过你继续，说你想说的吧。你知道，情况是这样的，我觉得这个世界变得有点两极分化了，感觉你要么是想听那种你差点死掉然后又死里逃生的故事，要么就索然无味，对吧？所以存在着这种极端，你知道的，我才不想听什么在一个共产主义罗马尼亚长大的小屁孩的支线故事呢。
It's not like, you know, what's funny about communists growing up on the right, on the wrong side of the iron curtain is, you know, it wasn't, it wasn't, um, you, you were not in peril of death on a regular basis. It was just bad, like bad in a sense that, you know, you a sense that you're not having good food, but you weren't really starving to death. You didn't have many opportunities, you didn't have much freedom, but it was like they would kill you. The killing occurred in the 50s. With Stalin, the whole killing thing became a thing that was, you know, passé, right? But it became some sort of a sordid existence.
这可不像——你知道的，在铁幕的错误一边长大，关于共产主义有什么好笑的呢，你知道的，其实并不是那种你经常面临生死关头的情况。情况只是很糟糕，糟糕的意思是，你知道的，你吃不到什么好东西，但你其实也没有饿死。你没有太多机会，也没有太多自由，但他们也不会直接杀了你。杀戮发生在50年代。随着斯大林的出现，杀戮整件事成了一种过去式，对吧？但它变成了某种肮脏阴暗的生活状态。
And it was, you know, my identity as an Eastern European in America is a bit, you know, what crazy refugee stories do I have to tell? Well, none. I have like, you know, I arrived in America by means of a plane. I didn't swim. I didn't go on a log or a raft, a life raft. I didn't starve almost to death and that kind of stuff. So I'm afraid that your listeners are going to be like, yeah, do I care about this guy? What stories could he possibly come up with?
而且你知道的，作为一个在美国的东欧人，我的身份有点——我到底有什么疯狂的难民故事可讲呢？好吧，完全没有。我是坐飞机抵达美国的，并没有游过来。我没有坐原木或者木筏、救生筏。我没有差点饿死之类的事情。所以我担心你们的听众会想：“行吧，我会在乎这家伙吗？他到底能扯出什么故事来？”
Oh, I know that is false. And I mean, I know, I'm not saying that I don't believe that you came by plane and I think you came by raft. What I mean is that I know it's false that you don't have stories. I just want to get back to the idea of traveling from Romania to the US by raft. I promised the listener, I promised the listener at some point I will introduce who we're speaking to because there's like half of you might not be C++ devs. But wait, we'll let Bryce talk about his raft.
噢，我知道这不是真的。我的意思是，我并不是说我不相信你是坐飞机来的，我觉得你是坐木筏来的。我的意思是，你没有故事可讲，这绝对是假的。我只是想回到从罗马尼亚坐木筏去美国这个话题上。我向听众保证，我向听众保证，我会在某个时刻介绍我们正在和谁对话，因为你们当中可能有一半人不是C++开发者。不过等等，我们先让布莱斯聊聊他的木筏。
What's up? You would need to cross the Black Sea, go through like the Turkish Straits, and then you'd be in the Mediterranean. And then you've got to like go across the Mediterranean, and then you've got to like go across the Mediterranean and then you got to like go past Gibraltar and then you got to go all the way to the US. That is quite the raft journey. Yep and you know the strait in Turkey has a really funny name, do you know it? I don't know it off the top of my head now. Now, here's the thing. Bryce, I'm not sure if I'm pronouncing it right.
怎么说？你得穿过黑海，通过类似土耳其海峡的路线，然后就到了地中海。然后你得横渡地中海，然后你得横渡地中海，然后你得穿过直布罗陀，接着你得一路去到美国。这真是一场相当了不起的木筏之旅啊。没错，你知道土耳其的那个海峡有个特别搞笑的名字吗？你知道吗？我脑子里一时想不起来了。事情是这样的，布莱斯，我不知道我发音准不准。
So you guys maybe are going to help me. Dardanelis. I mean, it sounds better than how I would pronounce it. It sounds plausible? Okay. The Dardanelis trade. Yeah, it would be a hike. It would be a hike.
所以你们几个或许可以帮帮我。达达尼尔（Dardanelis）。我是说，听起来比我念得要好听。听起来挺合理的吧？好吧。达达尼尔海峡。是的，那可真是一段漫长的旅程。那可真是一段漫长的旅程。
By means, of course, of a raft. All right. So no raft. Only planes. No no raft only planes only planes and you know there is a there is a kind of a true part of the story which is when i arrived i literally had 300 bucks on me so i that was it but i had friends who helped me get there and who uh had the job for me and that was of course it made all difference. I didn't arrive like a homeless guy in New York trying to make it on 300 bucks. So I had friends waiting for me
当然是通过木筏。好吧。所以没有木筏。只有飞机。没有，没有木筏，只有飞机，只有飞机。而且你知道的，故事里确实有一个真实的部分，那就是当我抵达的时候，我身上真的只有300美元，这就是我的全部身家。不过我有朋友帮我在那里安顿，他们帮我找好了工作，当然，这让一切都变得不同了。我可不是像个身无分文、试图靠300美元在纽约混出名堂的流浪汉那样抵达的。我有朋友在等我。
and they took me to their place, great people. And we worked together. I didn't start at Papa John's. Unlike Chandler, I'm very sad to announce that I do not have a Papa John's pizza worker experience. So I started as a programmer in New York in 1998. In 1998? Yep.
他们把我接到了他们住的地方，都是非常好的人。然后我们一起工作。我可没有从棒约翰（Papa John's）披萨店起步。跟钱德勒不同，我很遗憾地宣布，我没有在棒约翰做过披萨店员的经历。所以我是1998年在纽约开始当程序员的。1998年？没错。
I was already programming for a while, but that was my first American experience. Okay, so we're going to pause to introduce our guest. For those of you... Usually we have rough landings. We don't typically have. Rough beginnings. Although that was actually the case when we had Patricia and Chandler on. We didn't even realize that we had not introduced them.
我已经编程好一阵子了，但那是我的第一次美国经历。好的，我们要暂停一下来介绍我们的嘉宾。对于你们这些……通常我们的开场都很坎坷。我们通常不会有……艰难的开场。尽管当我们请来帕特里夏和钱德勒时确实是这样。我们甚至都没意识到自己还没介绍他们。
We just started talking. Yeah, I noticed that. Chandler just started talking about his backyard barbecue. Anyway, so our guest today, Andre Alexandrescu, hopefully I pronounced that correctly. I'll send you a well. C++ devs are probably almost 100% familiar with the name. This man has a Wikipedia page.
我们就直接开始聊天了。对，我注意到了。钱德勒一上来就聊起了他后院的烧烤。不管怎样，我们今天的嘉宾是安德烈·亚历山德雷斯库，希望我没有把他的名字念错。我会发音得很标准的。C++开发者对这个名字大概有将近100%的熟悉度。这个人可是有维基百科词条的。
Yeah, this man has a Wikipedia page. Actually, I'm not sure if this is most famously, but the book, Modern C++ Design, basically define a generation of template metaprogramming and started what ultimately has become, I don't know, constexpr metaprogramming. Like the journey all dates back. And here's, here's the sad thing. I haven't even read the book. That's how we could have done our research. Although I have, I have heard, even if the book, the template metaprogramming, you're not going to do much of it. The first two chapters,
对，这人有维基百科词条。其实，我不敢确定这是不是他最著名的成就，但那本书《C++设计新思维》（Modern C++ Design）基本上定义了一整代模板元编程，并且开启了最终演变成——我不知道，比如`constexpr`元编程的道路。这一切的旅程都要追溯到过去。最悲哀的是什么，你知道吗？我甚至都没读过这本书。这就是我们本该做好的调研。不过我听说，即使书里的模板元编程你用不上太多，前两章——
I'm not sure what's in the first two chapters, but I've heard the first two chapters are timeless and you should read those no matter what. But, but so Andre was a C++ mogul. He'll tell us what he was doing before then and has worked at Facebook, went on at one point, I think actually while you were at Facebook, you were working on the D language and we'll get into this. So I'm not actually sure if you know, you're one of the four horsemen of the Pacific Northwest C++ user group. That's a term that I came up with on a past episode. Bryce, were you remarking that maybe we could hire all four of them? Don't tell people my strategy. Because we've got half of them eric niebler part of that other half and then walter bright and bartosh maluski apparently the four of you i heard this from eric when did i have
我不太确定前两章里写了什么，但我听说前两章是永不过时的，无论如何你都应该读一读。总之，安德烈曾经是个C++大牛。他会告诉我们他之前在做什么，曾在Facebook工作过，在某个阶段——我想正是在你在Facebook的时候——你还在开发D语言，我们一会儿会聊到这个。所以我其实不确定你知不知道，你是太平洋西北地区C++用户组的“四大天王”之一。这是我在上一期节目里想出来的词。布莱斯，你刚才是不是在说也许我们可以把他们四个都雇下来？别把我的策略告诉别人。因为我们已经有了其中一半，埃里克·尼布勒是其中之一，然后还有沃尔特·布赖特（Walter Bright）和巴托什·马卢斯基（Bartosh Maluski）。你们四个人——我从埃里克那儿听说的，我第一次和他吃午餐是什么时候？要么是在一次CppCon上，要么是在委员会会议上，他向我提起你们过去是如何去参加C++用户组聚会，然后出去喝一杯，或者周末约着喝咖啡的。那是一个……的时代。
lunch with him for one of the first times it was either at a cpp con or at a committee meeting and he told me about you know how you guys used to go to the c++ user groups and then you'd go out for drinks or just meet up for coffee on the weekends. And there was this era of, you know. In 2011, I did that with the four. Maybe minus Andre, but it was in Seattle for my first supercomputing conference, the supercomputing conference, which was in Seattle that year. And I somehow became aware that there was the Northwest C++ user group meeting up there. And I went, and I think it was at someplace on Microsoft, some Microsoft campus. And afterwards, Walter, Eric, and I think Andre, and like some
2011年的时候，我和这四个人一起做过这事。也许除了安德烈，但那是当年在西雅图参加我的第一场超级计算会议（Supercomputing Conference）的时候，那一年的超级计算会议正是在西雅图举行的。我不知怎么得知西北地区C++用户组要在那里开会，于是我就去了，我想那大概是在微软的某个园区。后来，沃尔特、埃里克，还有安德烈，以及其他一些人去了一个酒吧，我也跟他们一起去了。我想，几乎没人会记得这事，因为那是我职业生涯的极早期。那大概是我职业生涯头六个月的时候，我还是个乳臭未干的小毛头。太棒了。我当时不在。我已经搬走了。对，对，对，对。所以，并非——并不是全部四个人。只有沃尔特、埃里克，还有——等等，第四个人是谁，康纳？巴托什·马卢斯基（Bartosz Maluszki）。巴托什。我不知道巴托什当时在不在。不，我觉得他在。
other people went out to some bar somewhere and I went with them. And I was like, I'm sure, I'm sure almost none of them remember that because that was like very early in my career. That was like my, the first six months of my career when I was still a little squirt. Awesome. I wasn't there. I'd moved already. Right, right, right, right. So it was, it was, it was not the, the, the, not all four of them. It was just Walter, Eric, um, uh, wait, who's the fourth, Connor? Bartosz Maluszki. Bartosz. I don't know if Bartosz was there. No, I think he was.
我觉得就是巴托什邀请的我。布拉德·罗伯茨（Brad Roberts）可能也参加了那次聚会。布拉德是亚马逊的工程师，我想他现在已经退休了。哦，天哪。我们要——哦天哪。看吧，这就是问题所在。这不是最润滑的介绍，因为我太激动了。对，这是一段冗长的介绍。
I think Bartosz was the one who invited me. Brad Roberts might have been part of the meeting. Brad was an Amazon engineer, and I think he retired by now. Oh, wow. We're going to, oh, my. See, this is the thing. This is not the most polished introduction because I'm so excited because. Yeah, it's a long-winded introduction.
没错，这是关于《C++设计新思维》的介绍，然后从那以后，我想我之前在播客里提到过，沃尔特·布赖特去搞了D语言，然后安德烈——我其实不太确定你是什么时候迅速加入进来的。2005年我加入了沃尔特。是的，然后你基本上就和沃尔特并肩作战，做了大量的算法工作。我们昨天在一个内部会议上做自我介绍时提到，刚刚被引入C++23的`chunk by`算法，它的名字就直接源自D语言。你在Facebook工作过，在无数的公司工作过，现在你在NVIDIA。总之，我要停止这段冗长的介绍，你来接话吧。我觉得我们可以从1998年开始，然后顺着往下聊。好吧，线性叙事，真有创意。所以，我不知道，我认为——哦，我认为，有许多决定对任何人来说都是非常重要的，特别是对任何工程师来说，需要做出几个重大的决定，其中之一就是移民，移民到美国，事实证明这是一个正确的决定。当然，也有可能当时我在那里有朋友和父母，而且已经有了舒适的职业前景。
It's yeah it's C++ modern C++ design and then from that I think I've mentioned this on the podcast before yeah Walter Bright went and did D and then Andre I'm actually not sure how quickly you ended up joining in. 2005 I joined Walter. Yeah and then you were basically you know worked side by side with Walter did a ton of of the, you know, algorithm stuff. We mentioned that yesterday in an internal meeting when we were sort of doing introductions that the chunk by algorithm that just got into C++23, the name of that comes specifically from D. And you've worked at Facebook, you've worked at a plethora of companies, and now you're at nvidia anyways i'm gonna stop this long-winded introduction you jump i guess mean we can start at 1998 and then we can just go from there and uh yeah um well uh linear storytelling that's original um so i don't know it's um oh i think um there's been a number of, and I think this is important for anyone really, and in particular any engineer, to make a few important decisions right and sort of to was to emigrate, to immigrate to the States and turns out that was a good decision and you know It might as well be that of course I had like friends and parents there and comfortable
到了90年代末，国家的经济状况已经在变好了。1989年共产主义倒台后，经历了大约十年的动荡期，但到了2000年代左右，情况开始改善。因此，高级人才备受推崇，因为他们为跨国公司工作，按照罗马尼亚的标准，他们的薪水非常高。情况就是这样。我认识不少人，他们其实选择拒绝来自国外的Offer，选择留在罗马尼亚。
career already Prospect the country was getting already economically better by by the end of the 90s it was there's this fall of the communism in 1989 and there's been like a decade of turmoil turmoil but but but by like the 2000s things had started to improve so and progress like in high esteem because they would work for international companies and they would be very well paid by Romanian standards. So there was a situation. I know quite a few folks who actually chose to turn down offers from abroad and they chose to live in Romania.
所以，一个正确的决定是，我搬走了。我搬到了美国，事实证明这是一件好事。我在华尔街工作了一年多，后来又去亚特兰大的一家初创公司工作。同样，也是通过朋友的引荐和面试之类的机会。你这个时候在写C++吗？对，我一直都在使用C++。
So, you know, one good decision was, you know, I moved out. I moved to the States and that turned out to be a good thing. So I worked on Wall Street for a year plus, and then I moved to a startup in Atlanta, it turns out. Again, just by means of a friend's word there, and interviewing and stuff. Are you doing C++ at this point? Yeah, I was using C++ all through.
在亚特兰大，那家公司叫NetZip，后来被RealNetworks收购了。所以我不确定你是否知道，这比你的全盛时期还要早。在2000年左右，RealNetworks可是个大公司。它是第一家做互联网音频和互联网电台之类无聊玩意的公司，后来他们转向了视频。我觉得他们现在成了——他们虽然还在，但现在只是个微不足道的边缘玩家了。RealNetworks收购了这家NetZip初创公司，我当时拿到了股票期权，当年拿的其实不是股票。我拿到了期权，在2000年1月收购刚刚完成的时候，我的期权价值40万美元。现在你想想，对于一个不久前——
And in Atlanta, that company was called NetZip and it got acquired by Real Networks. So I'm not sure if you even know, it predates your prime. Real Networks was kind of a big deal back then in the 2000, year 2000. And it was the first company that did like audio over the internet and kind of internet radio all that nonsense and then they switched to video and I think that they became you know they're they still around but they're a minor minor player by now and you know set real networks they bought this native startup and I got shares, options actually back in the day, they were not shares. So I got options and at the time of the acquisition in January 2000 straight, my options were worth $400,000. Now you gotta figure out for somebody who like just,
也就两岁（两年前）身上只有300美元的人来说，这可以说是对移民决定的一笔相当不错的投资回报了。所以那真是太棒了。当然，大家都知道接下来发生了什么。2000年1月几乎完美地对应了3月份的市场巅峰。到了3月，市场开始暴跌。
you know, two years ago had $300. That was like a pretty good return on investment on the decision to move abroad, you know? So that was pretty fantastic. And of course, you know, we know what followed. So January 2000 was almost like perfectly the peak of the market in March. By March, the market started to fall.
然后，基本上一切都化为乌有。有趣的是生活是如何为你安排这些事情的，因为看似最糟糕的事情，最后却带来了意想不到的好结果。比如2001年到来，基本上就是：嗯，我的期权一文不值了，而且我讨厌我的工作。里面还有很多办公室政治之类的事情。所以当时发生了很多令人不快的小细节。
And then, you know, essentially it all went to dust. And it's kind of funny how life organizes these things for you, because what seemed to be like the worst thing to happen turned out to have unexpected good consequences. For example, 2001 comes and essentially it's like, well, my options are worth nothing and I hate my job. It was also very political and whatever. So there's a lot of little unpleasant details about what was going on.
这一切都是由糟糕的经济形势造成的，对吧？当时整个科技行业都一团糟。但就在那时，我想，好吧，看起来我没什么可失去的了。那40万美金的好处现在账面上全都没有了。也就是在那时，我决定去读研究生。于是我去攻读我的博士学位。现在你们得明白，大多数人在申请博士学位时，都会申请很多学校。
And it was all caused by the dire situation of the economy, right? The whole tech sector was messed up back then. But at that point, I was like, well, it looks like I don't have much to lose. All of those good $400,000 are not in the books anymore. And that was when I decided to join the graduate school. So I went for my PhD. So now you got to appreciate that most people, when they apply for a PhD, they apply to like many schools.
这有一整套流程什么的。而我对这一切一无所知。我对整个流程完全零理解。所以我就像个傻子一样，打电话问：我所在的城市有什么大学？我当时在西雅图，所以西雅图有什么好大学？然后有人告诉我，是华盛顿大学。对方告诉我华盛顿大学是个相当了不起的地方，它是计算机科学领域的顶尖十所大学之一。但我当时完全不知道。搞笑的是，我什么都不知道这一点，反而成了让我被录取的原因。
And there's a whole like process and everything. And I have no idea about all that. I had zero understanding of the whole process. So I did like an idiot. I called like, what is the university in my city i was in seattle so what is a good university in seattle so you know somebody tells me it tells me it's like a university of washington tells us university of washington is kind of a pretty big deal like it's a top 10 university in computer science so but i had no idea and the funny thing is the fact that i had no idea was what put me in
因为如果你什么都知道，你就会觉得自己根本没戏，觉得他们绝对不会要我，我百分之百进不去。但因为我不知道，我就直接申请了，然后我成功了。于是，接下来的八年里，那段苦不堪言的故事就变成了我如何在那个大学拿到博士学位。期间发生了很多事情，我写了第二本书，也就是C++规范标准的书，还写了一堆文章、一堆论文、一堆……我结婚了，有了孩子，所以我的博士生涯同时伴随着很多事情发生。从2005年开始，我对D语言有着永无止境的热情，
Because if you had any idea I would have been like they will never want me I had no chance in hell to get to you though But because I didn't know I just applied and I made it so then you know the whole The sordid story of the next eight years was how I got my PhD in that the university and a lot has happened In the meantime I wrote my second book, the Cirrus Codex Standards book, a bunch of articles, a bunch of papers, a bunch of... I got married, had a kid, so a lot of stuff happened concurrently with my PhD. And all through, starting 2005, there's this unending passion for the D language,
我和沃尔特一起为它工作了——所以2005年到这会儿，大概是多少年了？16年了？所以这是一段很长的时间。从Facebook离开后，或者说——抱歉，从华盛顿大学毕业后，我拿到了学位。我觉得这也是另一个正确的决定：你要不要去读研究生？对某些人来说，这绝对不是正确的决定。但对 F我来说，事实证明是的。所以我很高兴自己做出了那个决定。
which I worked with Walter on for, you know, for... So 2005, that would be like, what, 16 years by now? So that's a long time. And after Facebook, I, you know, sorry, after University of Washington, I finished with my degree, which I'm very kind of, that was kind of another good decision that, you know, do you want to do a graduate degree? And for some people, it's definitely not the right decision. For me, it turned out to be. So I'm very happy to have made that one decision.
但你们得明白，康纳和布莱斯，你们得明白，在平常的一天里，我和你们任何人在内，可能都会做出十几个、半打或二十几个错误的决定，对吧？但关键是，它们都是小事。所以在生活中你会犯下所有这些小错误，在你的代码里也是如此——更不用说代码里的那些Bug和各种乱七八糟的东西了。当然，我的代码里从来不写Bug，我不写代码——除了在布莱斯看来。但如果你有这区区五个正确的决定，那么很多事情就会好得多。所以关键是要弄清楚，哪些地方应该做出好的决定，你的决策精力应该投入到哪里。
But you got to appreciate, Connor and bryce you gotta appreciate that that there may be in a regular day me and any of us would make maybe a dozen or half a dozen or two dozens wrong decisions right but the point is they're minor you know so you know you make all these mistakes and little mistakes in in life and it you know in your code not to mention in the code you bugs and all that nonsense of course i don't write bugs in my code i don't write code not not in prices but if you like these like five decisions that are right then uh a lot of things are going to be a lot better so it's important to figure out where the good decision should go, where your decision-making input should go.
所以，也许你买了一辆不怎么样的车，它不是辆好车，你可能为它多花了冤枉钱之类的。这是一个糟糕的决定，但也许它不是最糟糕的决定，也不会产生巨大的影响。但是，你是否加入一家公司，是否留在一家公司，是否去上学，是否继续留在学校里，以及所有这些——你和谁结婚，和谁建立恋爱关系，甚至你保留哪些朋友、不保留哪些朋友。这些都是相当重要的决定，你需要投入大量的精力，投入你大量的心理觉察。总之，我博士毕业后直接去了
So maybe buy a bad car and it's not a great car and you can pay too much for it or whatever. It's a bad decision, but maybe it's not the worst decision and it's not something that's going to have a huge impact. But whether you join a company or not, whether you are going to stay in company or not, whether you are going to go to school, stay in school or not. And all of these, you know, who do you marry and who do you have a relationship with, even what friends you keep and don't keep. These are kind of important decisions that you need to invest a lot in, you know, a lot of your mental kind of awareness into. So anyway, so straight after my PhD, I went with
Facebook，我在那里度过了一段美好的时光。我不认为我发挥出了全部的潜力。Facebook是一家崇尚面对面沟通的公司，而我是极少数的远程工程师之一。所以我可能只发挥了70%的产能。当时整个公司文化完全不支持远程办公，我不知道现在是什么样，但在当时，有任何远程员工都是极其罕见的。所以这产生了一些摩擦。我大概只发挥了70%的潜力。所以，我在那里待过，那是一次很好的经历。本可以更好的。我可以做得更多，但远程工作的整个环境就是这样。
Facebook where I've been. I've had a good time. I don't think I've been ever at full potential. Facebook is a face-to-face company and I was one of the very few engineers remote. So I was at maybe 70% of capacity. The whole culture was not remote at all back then. And I'm not sure what it's like right now, but back then it was like a rarity to have any employee who's remote. So it was a friction. So I had like maybe 70% of the potential. So I kind of, I've been there and it's been a good experience. It could have been better. I could have done more, but the whole circumstance with remote work was so-so.
然后我成了一个独立人士，你知道的，我离开了Facebook，成了一名独立顾问，结果我对此感到极其厌倦，这挺奇怪的。有些人很适合当独立人士，比如做培训、为其他公司提供咨询，这挺好的。但对我不行。我弄明白了原因，这也是我加入NVIDIA的原因。我会确切地告诉你为什么。我厌倦了，因为我想去“蹭”，我会准确解释我说的“蹭”是什么意思。
And then I became an independent, you know, I kind of left Facebook and I became an independent consultant and I got really tired of it, which is weird. Like there are people for whom being independent and kind of just doing a training, consulting for other companies and, you know, it's good. For me, it's not. And I figured out why. And that's why I joined NVIDIA. And I'll tell you exactly why. I got sick of it because i want to mooch and i i'll explain exactly what i mean by mooching
我想去“蹭”。我的意思是，我想在智力上“蹭”其他聪明人的光。我想要和那些——作为一个顾问，你按定义来说就是那个给予的人。所以，我们遇到了这个非常困难的问题，我们要请一个顾问来；或者我们的人需要C++培训，或者他们需要算法培训，或者他们需要性能培训，或者他们需要高性能计算培训，我们要请一个培训师。所以按定义，培训师或顾问的活动是孤立的。你独自备课，然后给予，对吧？你进行分享。
i want to mooch what i mean is i want to mooch intellectually off of other smart people I want collaborations with folks who are you know as a consultant you you're by definition that the person who is giving right so like so we have this really difficult problem so we're gonna bring in a consultant right or our people need C++ training or they need algorithms training or they need performance time or they need performance, high-performance computing training and we're going to bring a trainer. So by definition, the trainer's or consultant's activity is solitary. So you prepare a loan and then you give, right? You share.
你输出价值，对吧？如果你输出的价值不够，你就不是一个合格的培训师或顾问。但当你身处一个组织内部与其他人共事时，你是在“蹭”。这是双向的。有输入，也有输出。
You output value, right? And if you don't output enough value, you're not a good trainer or consultant. But when you work within an organization with someone else, you get too much. It's bidirectional. It's input and output.
因此，你能够与许多人展开合作，其中许多人可能比你更优秀，你可以在学习的同时进行分享。这就是为什么我加入NVIDIA会感到无比兴奋，因为这里有太多优秀的人了。我甚至惊讶地发现——其实我直到前天之前都不知道你在NVIDIA。
So you get to enter these collaborations with folks, many of whom can be better than you and you get to learn and share at the same time. And that's why I was very excited to join NVIDIA, because so many great people are here. I was actually surprised to see, like, even, I kind of had no idea you were at NVIDIA, like, until, like, the day before yesterday.
所以，我真的不是在开玩笑。我知道布莱斯是因为埃里克提过。埃里克是我最先联系的关于NVIDIA的人。那是一种这样的感觉：等一下，埃里克在NVIDIA？埃里克是个大好人。NVIDIA听起来像是一家很酷的公司。我当时对它了解不多。
So it's, I'm not kidding. I knew of Bryce because Eric mentioned it. Eric was the first whom I got in touch with about NVIDIA. And it was one of those things like, wait a second, so Eric is at NVIDIA. Eric is a great guy. NVIDIA sounds like a cool company. I didn't know much about it back then.
这就是——让我们这么做吧，因为回顾我作为孤立顾问的生活，其实并没有那么令人兴奋。你会变得麻木，你会觉得：又是一门新课程，好吧，好吧，钱确实不错，但你学不到东西，你没法学习，你没法“蹭”经验，对吧？所以“蹭”是个关键词，各位。我们得把这个——这将成为这期节目的开场白：我为什么加入NVIDIA？
That's, huh,'s let's do this because looking at my at my life as a as a solitary consultant what was not very exciting it you know you get blasé you get like you know i gotta kind of yet another course yeah yeah of course it's good money but it's uh just uh you don't you don't get to learn you don't get to learn, you don't get to mooch, right? So mooching is a keyword here, folks. We're going to have to put the, that's going to be the start of the episode. Why did I join NVIDIA?
为了去“蹭”。然后大家会困惑整整15分钟，直到他们听到后面的内容。是的，所以整件事运作的方式挺搞笑的，诸如此类的事情——比如这种学习的需求在其中占据了很大比重，还有一些其他因素也会进入画面，比如我认为对任何人来说都很重要的品质，例如谦逊。我认为现在谦逊作为一种人类品质被忽视了。每个人都想表现得自我，无论是什么，
To mooch. And then people are going to be confused for 15 minutes until they get to the part where the follow-up. Yeah, so it's kind of funny how this whole thing works um and uh things like um uh this need to learn have a lot to do with it and there are things that enter in in the picture like uh you know features that i think are important for for any person things like uh humility right so I think humility is overlooked nowadays as a human quality. Everybody wants to be like self, whatever,
自我……那个词叫什么？自信，还有自我肯定，所有这些外向的品质。但我觉得，谦逊对于一个程序员来说非常重要。而谦逊对工程师而言，意味着清醒地认识到有很多你可以学习的人，也有很多你不知道的事情。
self, what's the word? Self-confident and like self-affirming and all of these outgoing qualities. But humility, I think, is very important for a programmer. And humility, among other things, means for an engineer, is kind of having a good recognition that there are a lot of people you can learn from and a lot of things you don't know.
弄清楚你不知道什么、你想知道什么以及如何达成目标，这是你作为工程师成长过程中非常重要的一部分。所以，是的，我认为谦逊是一种不应该被忽视的有趣品质。对，我觉得凯特·格雷戈里（Kate Gregory）曾做过一次演讲。我想那次演讲的标题是《有情感的代码》（Emotional Code）。如果不是这个演讲，我会把它链接到Shownotes里。我很确信就是这个。太棒了。是的。她在其中提出的观点之一就是：你需要保持善良。
And figuring out what you don't know and what you want to know and how to get there is a very important part of your development as an engineer. So yeah, so humility, I think is an interesting quality that should not be overlooked. Yeah, I think isn't there, Kate Gregory gave a talk. I want to say the title of it was emotional code. But one of the if it's that's not the talk, I'll link it in the show notes. I'm pretty sure it is awesome. Yes. Yeah. And one of the points she makes in that is like, you need to be kind. Yeah. Like when you program, because, and it's not even like necessarily to your coworkers, it's to your future self.
是的。当你写代码的时候，甚至不是对你的同事保持善良，而是对未来的你自己。
Like, you know, in the moment you can have all the context, you understand the problem, but like take, take a step back and like, think about future you. And that sort of ties into the humility thing. Cause like, uh, if you're just, you know, oh, I know what this is doing blah blah you write it and then yeah yeah you can tell like you read code that you can tell how the person uh writing it felt and kind of what they were thinking i can i can read code and this guy had a really good time writing this code like they had fun with the language they had a good time and it shows and it it uh it's um you know it's this uh good disposition that it's uh contagious and you get like a you know oh wow that's really fun so i like it and
你知道，当下的你拥有所有的背景信息，你理解这个问题，但退一步想想未来的你。这其实和谦逊有点关系。因为，如果你只是表现得“哦，我知道这是在干嘛，巴拉巴拉”，然后你把代码写出来，是的，是的，你可以从代码里读出写代码的人当时的感受和他们的想法。我能读懂代码，这家伙写这段代码时一定过得很开心，他们在享受这门语言，他们玩得很愉快，而这一点跃然纸上。而且它是一种……你知道的，这种良好的心态是会传染的，你会忍不住感叹：“哦，太棒了，这真有意思，我喜欢。”
you get code that is like oh my god i can't believe i got this to work and i hate it and you can see that hatred in the code as well and indeed like kindness is a very good it's a very good quality for uh and a good disposition to put yourself in when you code. And by the way, Kate is the perfect person to teach that kind of stuff because she is kind. Yeah, no, definitely. So what should we, I mean, I'm definitely curious to hear more about the heydays of Niebler, Alexandrescu, Bright, and Bartosz. But I don't want to completely
你会看到这样的代码：“天哪，我真不敢相信我居然把这玩意儿弄跑了，我恨死它了。”你也能在代码中看到这种憎恨。确实，善良对于写代码的人来说是一种非常优秀的品质，也是一种极佳的心态。顺便说一句，凯特是教导这类事情的完美人选，因为她本人就很善良。是的，绝对如此。那么，我们应该——我是说，我绝对很好奇想听更多关于尼布勒、安德烈、布赖特和巴托什的全盛时期的故事。但我不想完全
commandeer. Bryce, do you before we hop to that? No, I got a thing too, but let's do your thing first. I got a thing too. I want to take this a different place. I want to confess. You drive. I want to confess something. Uh-oh, here we go. This is going to be this a different place. Okay. I want to confess. You drive, you drive. I want to confess something.
抢走话筒。布莱斯，在我们跳到那个话题之前，你还有什么想说的吗？不，我也有个事儿，不过咱们先聊你的事儿。我也有个事儿。我想把话题引向另一个方向。我要坦白。你来主导。我想坦白一件事。哦噢，来咯。这将会是——把话题引向另一个方向。好吧。我要坦白。你来，你来。我要坦白一件事。
Uh-oh, here we go. This is going to be our best episode ever. I also want to ask you, and essentially by extension your audience, like, you know, all of us would, you know, I'm having an open question for, you know, everybody. How many of you have the imposter syndrome
哦噢，来咯。这将会是我们史上最棒的一期节目。我还想问你，基本上也就是通过你向你的听众问一个问题：我们所有人中，有多少人有“冒名顶替综合征”？
bryce is not you guys you guys are good you're immune i definitely have it bryce and i've had this conversation bryce is from he's in nyoka and uh he does not well actually i should let bryce answer i i i i definitely think i don't one of the way reasons that like I believe this is I like talking with like Connor or some of my other friends about like their first interactions with like big figures in the C++ community um or like on the committee um made me realize how like just completely intimidated I am by people that here's the best here's the best analogy that I can give you when I worked at LSU I worked under Hartman Kaiser who's a great C++ programmer and who was very charitable and mentoring me early in my career I used to when I needed to go talk with Hartman about something,
布莱斯，你可不算，你们这群人太棒了，你们免疫了。我绝对有。布莱斯和我讨论过这个话题，布莱斯来自……他在纽约，他并不——其实，我应该让布莱斯自己回答。我绝对觉得自己没有。其中一个原因就是，我喜欢和康纳或者其他一些朋友聊聊他们初次接触C++社区里的大人物时的情景，或者他们在委员会上的经历，这让我意识到我面对那些人时是多么地畏缩。这里有一个我能给你的最佳类比：我在LSU（路易斯安安纳州立大学）工作时，是在哈特曼·凯瑟（Hartman Kaiser）手下工作，他是个伟大的C++程序员，在我职业生涯早期给予了我极大的慷慨指导。以前，当我需要找哈特曼谈点什么事情时，
or maybe I didn't even have something specific to talk about, but I would just go into his office, I would just barge in, and I would just go sit down in the chair in his corner. And if he was doing something, you know, I wouldn't necessarily interrupt. Sometimes I would. After about six months of working there, he pointed out to me that like, you know, you just like, you just, you don't even ask if you can come in. If the door's closed, you just bark in. Just like y'all in the place. And I'm just that way about everything. I just feel like I belong everywhere.
也许我甚至没有什么具体的事情要谈，但我就会直接走进他的办公室，径直闯进去，然后坐在他角落的椅子上。如果他在忙什么事情，你知道的，我也不一定会打扰他。有时我会。在那儿工作了大约六个月后，他向我指出：“你知道吗，你甚至都不问一下能不能进来。如果门关着，你就直接闯进来了。就像这地方是你的地盘一样。”我对待所有事情都是这样的态度。我总觉得自己属于任何地方。
But Connor, Connor, you've talked in the past. Yeah. So Bryce, admittedly, is not representative. He's very special. I mean, I don't think we've ever talked about this on the podcast, but I live – I don't actually – I don't say that I suffer from imposter syndrome. I just say that I have it. Like a part of the reason that I spend so much time consuming, you know,
但康纳，康纳，你过去也聊过这个。是的。所以，布莱斯必须承认，他并不具有代表性。他非常特别。我的意思是，我觉得我们以前从未在播客里谈过这个，但我活着——其实我不会说我饱受“冒名顶替综合征”之折磨。我只会说我有这东西。我花那么多时间去消费、了解——
podcasts and lectures and CPPCon talks and other languages is because, like, I feel like I started late because I did something else early in my career and I feel like I'm playing catch up with everyone, which admittedly, I think I've caught up, but I have this perpetual, not fear, but just how even at every level, you end up being in meetings where people are talking
播客、讲座、CppCon演讲以及其他语言的部分原因，是因为我觉得自己起步很晚，因为我职业生涯早期在做别的事情，我觉得我一直在拼命追赶所有人。当然，我想我已经赶上了，但我有一种永恒的——与其说是恐惧，不如说是一种感觉：无论在什么层面上，你最终总会发现自己身处这样的会议中：大家在交谈，
and assuming that you have a certain core set of knowledge that you don't. And I think part of being a senior engineer is having, feeling comfortable enough to like ask sort of not the stupid questions, but the questions that you're thinking in your head, oh, everyone else knows the answer to it. And that's something that Bryce and I've talked about that, you know, half of what Bryce does in meetings these days is, you know, sorry, can you slow down? I don't know what you're talking about. Can you please explain that? Whereas like, like that is like the difference between like certain levels of engineers is having the confidence to, I know enough that I know that this is a question that needs to be asked without being afraid that you're going to look like an idiot for pointing out that you don't have something that – it seems like people are – oh, they've assumed that I know this. Part of that is because when you're a senior
并且默认你具备某种核心知识库，而你其实并没有。我认为成为一名资深工程师的一部分，就是要有足够的舒适感去提出那些——不能说是愚蠢的问题，而是那些你在脑子里想“天啊，其他人肯定都知道答案”的问题。这也是我和布莱斯讨论过的事情，你知道的，布莱斯现在在会议上有一半时间都在说：“抱歉，你能慢点吗？我不知道你在说什么。你能解释一下吗？”然而，不同级别工程师之间的区别就在于拥有足够的自信：我知道得足够多，以至于我知道这是一个需要被提出来的问题，而不用担心因为指出自己不懂大家默认你懂的知识而显得自己像个白痴。部分原因在于，当你是一名资深
engineer, so when you're in a leadership role within a tech org, maybe just leadership role in general, it's not your job to know. I shouldn't know the answer to that because if I knew that, then that would mean that I spend a whole bunch of time focusing on that instead of focusing on the other things that I was supposed to focus on. Like the person who, you know, like there's somebody in my team who's like, it's their job to know that. And it's my job to know, to ask them. And then like, it's sort of both of our jobs for them to be able to transmit the useful, like the thing that I need to know about what they're doing or about that thing to me. Does that make sense? It does. And you know, Bryce, it seems to me like you have, you're an unusual combination of a sociable, gregarious guy and, and, you know, the introspective
工程师时——当你身处技术组织内的领导角色时，也许只是泛指领导角色——你的工作并不是什么都知道。我不应该知道那个问题的答案，因为如果我知道那个本该别人知道的答案，那就意味着我把大量时间花在了那上面，而不是花在我本该专注的其他事情上。比如，团队里有个人，了解那些就是他的工作。而我的工作是去问他们。然后，把他们正在做的事情或者我需要知道的事情有效地传达给我，这基本上成了我们两个人的共同工作。这说得通吗？确实说得通。而且，布莱斯，在我看来，你结合了一种罕见的特质：既是一个社交活跃、合群的家伙，又是编写代码所必需的内省型
guy you need to be to, in order to write code. So that's, that's pretty awesome. That, that, I think I like to think of myself as that. Yeah. That's rare. And Connor, you know, you do have a bit of like, yeah, like 0.1% of kind of imposter syndrome, but dude, you're a happy, you do have a bit of like 0.1% of imposter syndrome. But dude, you're a happy-go-lucky guy. I'm listening to what you say about your feelings and stuff. Man, you're a little kid. Let me tell you what imposter syndrome is like. Okay, so now we're going to get educated.
人才。这真的很酷。我喜欢把自己看作这样的人。这太罕见了。康纳，你知道的，你确实有一点——大概0.1%的“冒名顶替综合征”，但老兄，你是个随遇而安的乐天派。听你讲你那些感受之类的话，天哪，你就像个小孩子。让我来告诉你什么才叫真正的“冒名顶替综合征”。好了，接下来我们要接受教育了。
So I have this feeling that um and i'll be very honest here like this is like therapy man this is therapy um i have the feeling that for example i was interviewing so one of my interviews with nvidia was with bryce himself right and i was seriously considering of talking myself down during the interview I was like because everybody's like oh yeah so here's the thing so you know I put together this resume which is like like surgery man it's like you know it's like heart life heart surgery for me to write a resume because a resume must look good in the resume right and uh it's very difficult for me to um to talk about myself in these like uh overly
所以我有这种感觉，嗯，而且我在这里会非常诚实，就像这就像心理治疗一样，老兄，这就像心理治疗，嗯，我有这种感觉，例如，我当时在面试，我跟NVIDIA的其中一场面试就是跟Bryce本人，对吧，我当时真的在考虑在面试中自我贬低，我当时想，因为每个人都，哦，对，事情是这样的，你知道，我整理了这份简历，这就像外科手术一样，老兄，这就像，你知道，写简历对我来说就像心脏手术一样，因为简历在简历上必须看起来很好，而且，呃，对我来说，在这些像，呃，过于
optimistic terms so then i was thinking like god there's this interview and it turns out that the interviews were very um friendly like you know i did not get those like hard questions nobody came to and i said you know resolve like solve p equals mp you know or whatever somebody came with the hard questions to me they're like uh actually miles nice and kind of trying to sell the company tell me what they do and that kind of stuff and i was thinking i should tell them that actually i'm not that good as they think i am from my resume because the resume is too nice you know and that kind of stuff and uh in the end like nvidia made me this offer and you know they said um oh uh we uh you interviewed for um senior research scientist but we think you're good for principal uh research scientist
乐观的词汇中谈论自己是非常困难的，所以我当时想，天哪，有这样一场面试，结果证明面试非常，呃，友好，你知道的，我没有遇到那些很难的问题，没有人来，我说，你知道，解决，比如解决P等于NP问题，你知道，或者随便什么，有人拿难题来问我，他们说，呃，其实迈尔斯很好很亲切，某种程度上试图推销公司，告诉我他们是做什么的以及诸如此类的事情，我当时想，我应该告诉他们，其实我并没有他们从我的简历中想象的那么好，因为简历太好看了，你知道，诸如此类的事情，呃，最后，英伟达给了我这个offer，你知道，他们说，呃，哦，我们，我们，你面试的是，呃，高级研究科学家，但我们认为你适合资深，呃，研究科学家
i was like are you sure Are you sure you meant that? So it was very funny. In the end, I made a pact with myself. I told myself the following. I think I didn't lie during my interview. I think the resume is actually factually, the facts in there are at least like correct. There's no lie.
我当时想，你们确定吗？你们确定是这个意思吗？所以这非常有趣。最后，我和自己达成了一个协议。我对自己说了以下的话。我觉得我在面试时没有撒谎。我觉得简历实际上在事实上，里面的事实至少是正确的。没有谎言。
There's no kind of, you know, big lie in there, right? Oh my God, big lie. Why did I say these words? So there's no like ostensible lying in there so you know they had all the information in hand when they made the you know when they made the decision to make the software so I'll go with it so here I am here we are you guys but I think I think this is a huge thing on my shoulder here. And I noticed that many other folks have it. That's why I wanted to open up about it.
没有什么，你知道的，里面有什么弥天大谎，对吧？天哪，弥天大谎。我为什么要说这些话？所以里面没有那种表面上的谎言，所以你知道他们拿到所有信息时，做出了，你知道，当他们决定给出这个offer时，所以我就接受了，所以我就在这里，我们在这里，伙计们，但我认为，我认为我肩上背负着巨大的压力。我注意到其他许多人也有这种感觉。这就是为什么我想公开谈论它。
And maybe other folks can relate to that kind of stuff. Maybe not many care. Go ahead. I certainly feel very comfortable in tech communities, and I've never felt like I don't belong. I have, you know, the past few years I've switched into more of a leadership role at work and less of like a day to day engineering role. And I think I'm not the best programmer by a long shot. And I certainly think I feel some amount of inadequacy from that. Like I have some days where I'm like, did I do anything of value or am I just like,
也许其他人能对这种事情感同身受。也许没多少人在乎。请说。我在科技社区里确实感到非常自在，而且我从来不觉得自己不属于这里。我有，你知道，在过去的几年里，我在工作中更多地转到了领导角色，而日常的工程角色相对较少。而且我认为远谈不上我是最好的程序员。我当然觉得这带来了一定程度的不胜任感。比如我有些日子会想，我是做了什么有价值的事，还是我只是，
am I just like an executive producer that sticks my name on things? Right. And I think like even when I was programming 100% of the time, then I've had like a different feeling of inadequacy where I would be like, I spent the past three months working on X thing. And was that really valuable? Yeah, it becomes trivial to you. You know everything about it. It becomes trivial to you.
我是不是就像一个把名字挂在各种事情上的执行制片人？对吧。而且我认为，甚至当我百分之百的时间都在编程时，我也会有一种不同的不胜任感，我会觉得，我过去三个月都在搞X这件事情。这真的很有价值吗？是的，对你来说这变得微不足道了。你对它的一切了如指掌。它对你来说变得微不足道了。
But everybody else is actually, oh, this is kind of real heavy stuff. And it's like, no, it's trivial. I mean, I know it inside now out by now yeah and and it's like one of those i think it's especially like given you know we as software programmers are very well compensated um and you know sometimes like i think i question like are we just like very overpaid um and like i think i sort of intellectually understand how I provide value to my company. And at least on paper, provide some form of value to society. But, you know, I think that especially for people that set high goals for themselves,
但其实对其他人来说，哦，这相当沉重。然后就会觉得，不，这很trivial（微不足道）。我是说，到现在为止我对其了如指掌，对，并且，这就像其中之一，我觉得特别是鉴于，你知道，我们作为软件程序员，薪酬非常丰厚，而且你知道，有时，我想我会质疑，我们是不是只是拿了太多的薪水，而且，我想我在某种程度上从理性上理解我如何为公司提供价值。至少在纸面上，为社会提供某种形式的价值。但是，你知道，我认为特别是对于那些给自己设定崇高目标的人，
you also can be really tough on yourself. And you can feel like you're not doing enough. And I think these are good questions to ask oneself as a programmer. Like, you know, am I overpaid? And sort of by definition, because it's a market economy, you're not. So by a very simple definition of supply and demand,
你对自己也会非常严格。你会觉得你做的不够。我认为这些是程序员应该问自己的好问题。比如，你知道，我薪水过高了吗？从某种定义上来说，因为这是市场经济，你并没有。所以从供求关系的非常简单的定义来看，
you may consider yourself lucky as much as like an nba player may consider or like kind of baseball i just read this thing about baseball it turns out like 90 of the the quality of a pitcher is like genetic you just can't train it it's just you're born with it or you're not and you're either a great pitcher or you know also ran you know um so you may consider yourself lucky. Have like this particular thing that people want and need. And by the way, Bryce,
你可能会觉得自己很幸运，就像一个NBA球员可能会认为，或者像棒球，我刚读到关于棒球的这件事，结果发现一个投手的质量有90%是基因决定的，你根本无法训练它，你生来如此，要么就是，你要么是一个伟大的投手，要么，你知道，也是个跑龙套的，你知道，所以你可能会觉得自己很幸运。拥有人们想要和需要的这种特定东西。顺便说一句，Bryce，
that brings me to the, you know, not the second because it's actually the most important. The reason I, the first reason I joined NVIDIA was because I think NVIDIA is where the action is in computing. And I think,VIDIA is where the action is in computing. And I think we have humanity, for the lack of a more modest word, is facing these big problems. Climate and what do we do with all the plastic and energy and that kind of stuff. How do we solve these big
这让我想到了，你知道，不是第二个，因为这实际上是最重要的。我加入英伟达的原因，第一个原因是因为我认为英伟达是计算领域大有可为的地方。而且我认为，英伟达是计算领域大有可为的地方。而且我认为我们人类，用一个不那么谦虚的词来说，正面临着这些大问题。气候问题，我们如何处理所有的塑料、能源以及诸如此类的事情。我们如何解决这些宏大的
problems and it seems to me that ai is a big part of it and you know i'm not an expert in ai i've done some but i can't consider myself on the forefront of artificial intelligence but at least i i can provide shovels you know i can actually provide tools to people who um who work on these important problems and it's actually fascinating to witness how NVIDIA has this breadth you know from hardware oh actually we own the compiler we can introduce that feature if we need to you know which is kind of amazing because no other company most other companies are like well we have GCC and you know by the, you need to use version 9 because that's where we are right now. So I think NVIDIA is where the action is in computer science and in important problems to be solved.
问题，在我看来，人工智能是其中很大的一部分，你知道，我不是人工智能专家，我做过一些，但我不能认为自己处于人工智能的最前沿，但至少我可以提供铲子，你知道，我实际上可以为那些从事这些重要问题的人提供工具，而且见证英伟达如何拥有这种广度其实是非常迷人的，你知道，从硬件，哦，事实上我们拥有编译器，如果需要的话我们可以引入那个特性，你知道，这真是太棒了，因为没有其他公司，大多数其他公司都会说，嗯，我们有GCC，你知道，顺便说一句，你需要使用9版本，因为我们现在就在那。所以我认为英伟达是计算机科学中大有可为的地方，也是解决重要问题的地方。
Not to mention things like self-driving. That would lift a lot of issues for humankind if we solve self-driving to perfection. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
更不用说自动驾驶之类的事情了。如果我们把自动驾驶完美解决，这将为人类消除很多问题。感谢收听。希望你们喜欢，祝大家有美好的一天。这集节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。